what I have been able to set out in the
open part of volume three
is that I have found a significant
missed opportunity to take action that
might have prevented the attack
it is not possible to reach any
conclusion on the balance of
probabilities or to any other evidential
standard as to whether the attack would
have been prevented
however
there was a realistic possibility that
actionable intelligence could have been
obtained which might have led to action
preventing the attack
the reason for this missed opportunity
included a failure by the security
service in my view to act swiftly enough
I am aware that revealing what I have
revealed in part 24 of my report
will leave many people and particularly
the bereaved families wanting to know
more
all I can say is I have done my best to
reveal what I can